Theo gì đang sĩnh ra khi hàng loạt thong họ, nghe xí cũng rất hiện tại một sự kiện của thương hiệu bất động sản.
Công phải lễ mở bán cũng không phải giữa thiệu dự án,
từ ngày 1 vài tháng tư để ngày 1 chiến tháng tư tại Thủ Thêm River Stise,
chỉ là môn viện nhân xin của thương hiệu bất động sản vàn phủ chính thức hai mạnh,
với sự góc mặt của nhiều nghe xí nổi tiếng như họ khánh vân, kì duyên, tiên ơn, cà xí đang khôi, vình khóc.
Không đơn thần là một không gián trình bệnh, chỉ là mục thích kế như một thành trình trình trình dựa đàn sát quan,
đám chim trong không dành thí giá, ấm thành đến những khách cá nhân hóa đầy cảm xúc.
Đặc biệt, bởi nhật kịch tổ ấm đảng giá bao nhiêu khiến người xem không chỉ xem vệ thuật,
mà chực tiếp mức vào không chuyện của chính mình, để cảm nhận,
lưu trọn và tìm giá câu trả lời về giá và giá chỉ của tổ ấm.
Đây được xem là cách làm khóc biệt của văn phủ khi tiếp cận thị trường thành phố không hủ chính mình không vất đầu từ sản phẩm.
Mà từ con người và tránh nghiệm sống, qua đó,
trước lý phing and sinh được thị hình gió nát không chỉ trong không dành trình lám,
mà con trong cách dân nghiệp kế câu chuyện về bất đầu sản.